en el último vídeo probamos esta fórmula
la fórmula de valles también lo podemos
llamar el teorema de valles y pues si lo
probamos de forma analítica porque esa
es la forma de probar este tipo de
fórmulas pero bueno en este vídeo vamos
a usar la fórmula de valles el teorema
de valles para encontrar esta
probabilidad algo importante con estas
fórmulas que en realidad son bastante
fáciles de deducir es que no tienen que
ser unas fórmulas que uno se tenga que
memorizar y que si se equivoca uno por
una letra y ya no se acuerda cómo va la
fórmula ya se echó a perder todo nada
este tipo de fórmulas y de hecho la
mayoría de las fórmulas uno las puede
recordar más fácil si sabe cómo
demostrar las lo que hay bueno en este
caso de hecho ni siquiera tienen que
acordarse de ellas solo tiene que poder
volver a deducir la cada que la necesite
y bueno de hecho yo no siempre me
acuerdo de esta fórmula a cada rato
tengo que repetir la demostración que
vieron en el último vídeo y además así
uno entiende por qué son las fórmulas
como son pero bueno regresando calcular
esta probabilidad a este evento esta
condición de que no salgan 5 soles en 5
volados le vamos a llamar a y a esta
otra condición de que hayamos tomado la
moneda que tiene 2 soles le vamos a
llamar el evento o la condición de ok
entonces lo que nos dice la fórmula de
valles es que esta probabilidad que
ahora toma la forma de probabilidad debe
dado a es igual a la división de
probabilidad de adado b eso es la
probabilidad de el evento a que es que
nos hayan salido 5 soles
soles dado que sucedió el evento b y el
evento be es que hayamos tomado la
moneda que tiene 2 soles por la
probabilidad del evento b que es que
hayamos tomado la moneda de 2 soles
entre la probabilidad de el evento a que
es que hayan salido 5 soles soles
entonces esto de aquí es exactamente
esta probabilidad que tenemos por acá
que es un 1 la probabilidad de sacar la
moneda que tiene 2 soles la sacamos hace
dos vídeos y es súper sencilla tenemos
una urna con 10 monedas y sólo una de
ellas tiene dos soles o sea que es una
probabilidad de 1 entre 10 y finalmente
la probabilidad de que saquemos 5 soles
en 5 volados está también la sacamos
hace dos vídeos y ya no me acuerdo cómo
iba así sí
bien la sacamos en el vídeo pasado y el
chiste es que tenemos que sumar la
probabilidad de que nos hayan salido 5
soles y hayamos tomado una moneda normal
más la probabilidad de que nos haya
salido 5 soles y hayamos tomado la
moneda que tiene 2 soles ok creo que el
vídeo quería hacer hincapié en este
asunto y se me olvidó hacerlo pero bueno
el chiste es que si juntamos a estos dos
conjuntos lo que nos queda es justo este
conjunto ok este es el conjunto rosa que
estaba dentro del conjunto azul y este
en el conjunto rosa que en realidad era
igualito al conjunto amarillo ok pero
este y este conjunto son 10 juntos no
hay ni un solo punto que se encuentre en
estos dos conjuntos lo podíamos ver en
esa gráfica y lo podemos pensar ahorita
porque si sacamos una moneda normal
obviamente nos sacamos la moneda que
tiene dos soles y viceversa si sacamos
la moneda que tiene dos soles obviamente
nos sacamos la moneda normal entonces
estos dos conjuntos son distintos así es
que la probabilidad de su unión es igual
a la suma de sus probabilidades y su
unión es esta cosa de aquí ok bien el
chiste es que este conjunto tenía
probabilidad 9 entre 10 por un
32avos y este conjunto de aquí tenía
probabilidad un décimo entonces todo
junto es igual a
41 entre
320 cierto bien entonces realizamos esta
operación y aplicamos la ley del
sándwich este con este y este con este y
nos queda
320 entre
410 dividimos entre 10 de los dos lados
y sacamos la calculadora 32 entre 41
puntos 78
más o menos igual punto 78 porque
entonces si te fijas esto es súper
probable o sea tiene una probabilidad
mayor a tres cuartos ok entonces aquí
tenemos una probabilidad muy alta que no
nos asegura que tenemos la moneda que
tiene dos soles lo que sabemos es que
teníamos una urna tomamos una moneda no
sabemos si tomamos la moneda de dos
soles o una moneda normal lo que sí
sabemos es que a la hora de tirar cinco
volados nos salieron cinco soles y lo
que hace eso es que la probabilidad de
que la moneda que tenemos en las manos
sea la que tiene dos soles es más o
menos puntos 78 que es más grande que
tres cuartos podemos tratar de verlo
visualmente a ver veamos por aquí está
nuestro universo de resultados y
decíamos que por aquí una décima parte
de este universo es en la que sacamos la
moneda que tiene dos soles sí porque
está en la normal y por aquí estaba el
conjunto en el que tenemos una moneda
normal pero salen 5 soles seguidos ok se
acuerdan de este dibujo en el vídeo
pasado bueno y entonces lo que el
teorema de valles nos dice lo que esta
fórmula nos dice es que si nosotros
observamos que salieron 5 soles en 5
volados lo que tenemos que hacer es
restringir nos a ese espacio aunque y
así es que tomamos
este espacio
y ahora decimos que vivimos en este
universo y que los únicos resultados del
experimento que podemos obtener son los
que están aquí adentro de este nuevo
conjunto y por eso dividimos entre la
probabilidad de este conjunto porque de
esa forma estamos haciendo que la
probabilidad de todo este conjunto sea 1
aunque si ponemos aquí a la probabilidad
de ha dado a es 1 y la probabilidad de
aquí se cancela con la probabilidad de
ahí nos queda un 1 y esta es la forma de
decir que este es nuestro nuevo universo
lo cual tiene mucho sentido no ósea
porque como ya observamos que salieron 5
soles entonces todo nuestro universo
tiene que estar aquí cualquier resultado
del experimento como ya observamos que
salieron 5 soles está en este conjunto
que tiene a todos los resultados en los
que ya salieron 5 soles bueno entonces
ahora vamos a ver la parte de arriba
intuitivamente de dónde sale
lo que hacemos es preguntarnos de todo
este conjunto en el que salieron 5 soles
en qué pedazo de ese conjunto salieron
los 5 soles porque que la moneda que
escogimos es la moneda que tiene 2 soles
y bueno pues ese conjunto es este ok
además este conjunto lo podemos escribir
como que nos salió la moneda 2s
2s y nos salieron 5 soles o sea estamos
dentro del universo amarillo 5 soles
seguidos ahora para sacar su
probabilidad pues sabemos cómo lo vimos
en el vídeo pasado que podemos hacer eso
de las probabilidades condicionales por
la probabilidad de este evento y
entonces lo que tenemos aquí es justo
qué proporción del área amarilla que es
el área que nos interesa porque ya
sabemos que sucede esta condición qué
proporción de esa área amarilla es en la
que tenemos una moneda en la que hay dos
soles entonces si queremos sacar esa
pues tenemos que sacar esa área que es
esta misma y dividirla entre el área
total de nuestro universo así es que ese
es como que una explicación visual de la
fórmula de valles y es súper útil y
estoy segura de que la vamos a volver a
usar en algún otro momento
bueno nos vemos pronto